Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: Ms Buffard's students
C'est la première sortie
de mes années collège.
Pour la plupart des élèves de ma classe,
c'est une sortie comme les autres.
Ce jour-là, j'ai onze ans
et je visite la brasserie de Sochaux.
Je sens cette odeur chaude, envoûtante,
caramel, noisettes grillées,
une odeur qui me rappelle
le petit-déjeuner.
C'est l'odeur du malt chaud.
Je vois ces cuves, rutilantes, immenses.
On dirait des cathédrales de cuivre.
Je me sens tout petite à côté.
Dans une autre salle,
je vois des cuves
de fermentation ouvertes,
alignées les unes contres les autres.
Ces cuves ouvertes, je me penche
et je vois la fermentation sous mes yeux.
Je vois les hautes mousses.
On dirait des choux-fleurs qui gigotent.
Et cette odeur, cette odeur
si forte, si âcre, acide,
vraiment très, très particulière,
c'est l'odeur de la fermentation.
Mais bon maintenant vous connaissez
ma Madeleine de Proust.
Ces deux odeurs, le malt chaud,
la fermentation,
ce sont deux odeurs que je retrouve
à chaque fois
que je rentre dans une brasserie.
Alors, certains rentrent dans les ordres.
Eh bien moi, j'ai décidé
de rentrer en brasserie.
Et à travers ce choix, je visite,
je voyage dans le monde entier
pour visiter des brasseries,
qu'elles soient artisanales, nationales,
minuscules ou planétaires.
Dans chaque brasserie,
je retrouve ces deux odeurs.
Je suis rentrée en brasserie.
La bière, c'est mon univers.
C'est vraiment là
où je me sens bien, la bière.
Non. Pas la bière. Non, non, non.
Les bières. LES Bières, les bières
On boit de la bière.
On déguste des bières.
Alors si je vous pose maintenant
une question.
Si je vous dis le mot bière,
qu'est-ce que vous allez me répondre ?
Je vais entendre des mots comme :
boisson d'homme, ventre à bière,
bide à bière, boisson beauf, pizza-foot.
La bière, ça ballonne.
La bière, ça fait grossir.
La bière c'est amer.
J'aime pas la bière.
Celle-là, je l'entends tout le temps.
Et vous alors ? Allez-y.
Posez moi la question, allez.
Je vais vous dire les mots :
pain liquide,
femme brasseuse, déesse,
origine de la civilisation,
fécondation, boisson nourricière,
moisson, renouveau, nature,
Gilgamesh, Mésopotamie, Egypte,
Grèce, Hildegarde de Bingen,
moine trappiste, magique, alchimique,
mystérieuse, multimillénaire.
Alors, je vais vous raconter
l'histoire des bières.
Et je vous assure que vous allez
remonter le temps avec moi.
Ça va nous remonter très, très loin.
Au début du Néolithique,
les premières céréales apparaissent.
C'est de l'orge.
Les céréales sont cueillies.
Elles sont cultivées.
Les premiers pains liquides naissent.
C'est le début de l'agriculture.
C'est le début de notre civilisation.
C'est l'histoire des bières.
En Mésopotamie, nous allons
déchiffrer sur des tablettes d'argile
l'histoire, les recettes de cette boisson
qu'on appelle Sikaru,
qui va du pain d'orge émietté
dans du jus de dattes,
à cette boisson parfumée
de thym, de genièvre,
de cumin et de genévrier.
En Égypte, il y a une brasserie
même dans le temple de Néfertiti,
parce que la bière
est boisson d'offrande.
Toujours en Egypte,
nous rencontrons cette femme brasseuse,
qui brasse à pleines mains,
symboliquement,
comme elle pétrit le pain.
Les femmes sont les premiers brasseurs.
Les femmes font le pain,
elles font la bière à la maison.
Au Moyen-Âge,
les monastères apparaissent.
Les brasseries monacales se développent.
Au premier mois de brasseur,
à Saint-Denis, Charles le Chauve,
en 862, offre des boisseaux d'épeautre
pour faire de la cervoise.
Nous allons en Bourgogne, à Cîteaux.
Vous connaissez Cîteaux,
les moines cisterciens qui y habitent.
Ils observent la règle de Saint Benoît.
Cette règle, certains moines
ne l'ont pas trouvée assez dure.
Ils veulent une règle plus stricte.
Donc ils s'en vont s'établir à Trappe.
C'est un petit village de Normandie.
Ils y fondent l'abbaye de la Trappe.
Eh bien oui,
les bières trappistes sont nées en France,
contrairement à ce qu'on peut croire.
Et c'est à la Révolution,
un peu plus tard,
que ces mêmes moines de la Trappe,
sont obligés de s'exiler.
Et où vont-ils ?
Ils atterrissent là, entre autres,
dans un petit village en Belgique,
à Westmalle.
Peut-être le connaissez-vous.
Ils y fondent l'abbaye de Westmalle.
Eh bien,
c'est assez curieux tout de même,
que les très fameuses bières trappistes
de l'abbaye de Westmalle,
soient nées
à cause de la Révolution Française.
Une femme, brasseuse, abbesse,
la plus fameuse d'entres elles,
s'appelle Hildegarde de Bingen.
Cette femme, elle fonde son abbaye
en 1147, en Allemagne.
Elle est médecin, en plus d'être
brasseuse et abbesse,
et elle connaît les plantes.
Elle a une très, très grande
connaissance des plantes.
Elle découvre entre autres
dans ses recherches sur les plantes
que le houblon
a cette caractéristique incroyable
de conserver les aliments.
C'est très utile pour la bière,
parce que la bière, ça a du mal
à se concerter jusque là.
Petit à petit, le houblon rentre
dans la cervoise, qui à la base,
n'a pas de houblon.
Et c'est ainsi que le houblon
se généralise dans la bière.
Le mot bière apparaît d'ailleurs
au 15e siècle,
au moment où le houblon est généralisé.
Nous allons en Angleterre,
et nous allons rencontrer
des femmes brasseuses fameuses.
Ce sont les Alewives.
Leurs bières sont si fameuses,
qu'on se précipite chez elles
pour aller les goûter.
Leurs maisons deviennent
des public houses
qui vont préfigurer les futurs pubs.
Retournons un petit peu au grain d'orge.
Au printemps, on va semer l'orge.
En été, on le récolte.
En automne, l'orge se repose,
c'est la dormance de l'orge.
En hiver, nous sommes en octobre,
et c'est le temps de brasser.
Alors, pourquoi ?
Eh bien parce que, pour faire
de la bière, il faut du froid.
En été, c'est difficile
de faire de la bière
parce que les brassins
s'infectent, tournent.
"En hiver brasse qui veut,
en été brasse qui peut."
Il y a même un arrêté royal en 1709,
qui interdit de brasser
avant le 1er octobre.
C'est ainsi que les brasseurs,
de tout temps,
ont calé leur calendrier brassicole,
sur les calendriers des saisons,
tout simplement.
Et c'est ainsi que la magie
de la nature opère :
le cycle de l'orge, le cycle de la bière,
le cycle de l'orge, le cycle de la bière..
Jusqu'au 19e siècle, fin du 19e siècle,
les brasseurs respectent
ce rythme des saisons.
Évidemment, bien sûr, maintenant,
ils ne sont plus du tout obligés
de suivre ce rythme des saisons.
Le froid industriel a été inventé
à la fin du 19e.
Eh bien tous ? Non, pas tous,
parce qu'il y a quelque brasseurs
qui continuent à respecter
ce rythme de la nature.
Nous allons à Bruxelles.
Je vous emmène à Bruxelles,
dans une de ces mythiques brasseries,
vous savez, qui s'appellent Cantillon.
Là, sous la toiture,
dans le grand bac rouge de cuivre,
c'est la nature qui féconde le mou,
durant une nuit,
pendant la saison d'hiver.
Comme le dit Jean-Pierre Van Roy,
le brasseur qui s'est battu,
vraiment battu, pour que
ce rythme des saisons soit conservé,
et il a eu bien raison.
Jean-Pierre Van Roy dit :
« Moi, brasseur, mondialement connu,
je ne suis rien à côté de la nature
parce que c'est elle qui fait tout. »
Je pense, Messieurs dans la salle,
je suis sûre que vous n'y comprenez
pas grand chose parfois aux femmes.
J'ai entendu souvent ce genre de phrases.
Eh bien rassurez-vous,
le brasseur, il est comme vous,
mais en plus, il ne comprend pas,
mais alors pas du tout,
ce qui se passe dans sa cuve,
pendant des millénaires et des siècles.
C'est absolument incroyable
ce qu'il se passe,
cette transformation entre le grain d'orge
et la boisson qui en sort, c'est magique.
C'est tellement magique,
que dans la salle de brassage,
le symbole de la bière,
c'est l'étoile des brasseurs.
Cette étoile, elle est formée
des 4 symboles alchimiques,
des 4 éléments qui constituent
la fabrication de la bière.
C'est l'eau, la terre, l'air et le feu.
Et il n'y a aucun brasseur, aucun,
jusqu'à la fin du 19e siècle,
qui aurait laissé sa salle de brassage,
sans la protection de cette étoile.
Cette boisson magique,
elle est également mystérieuse.
Dans le premier récit de l'humanité,
l'épopée de Gilgamesh,
une fois qu'il est arrivé
au bout de la Terre,
c'est la déesse de la fermentation,
qui lui offre à boire de la bière.
Et cette boisson,
elle est faite dans un chaudron.
Le chaudron, cet objet rituel,
présent absolument dans
toutes les mythologies,
dans toutes les cultures :
le chaudron d'abondance,
le chaudron d'immortalité,
le chaudron magique.
Cette boisson mystérieuse et magique,
elle est également nourricière,
la cervoise.
Vous connaissez, la cervoise ?
Eh bien la cervoise,
ça veut dire force des céréales.
Parce que Ceres est la déesse des céréales
et Vis en latin, c'est la force.
Cette boisson nourricière,
c'est l'aliment de base
pendant des millénaires,
La boisson que les moines
donnent aux pèlerins pour les rassasier.
C'est la boisson
que les marins au long cours
emportent sur leurs bâteaux
contre le scorbut et la pelagre.
C'est la boisson
qui favorise l'allaitement.
Oui, absolument,
c'est une croyance populaire
mais je vous assure
qu'elle est démontrée scientifiquement.
On en trouve d'ailleurs
dans les pharmacies
jusque dans les années 50,
des bières de nourrices.
Cette boisson nourricière,
elle fait penser à un objet,
symbole même de la vie, l’œuf à levure.
L’œuf à levure !
Un objet unique, incroyable.
Cet objet renferme le secret
de la bière en devenir : la levure.
Vous avez tous lu Les Maîtres de l'Orge" ?
La levure, c'est l'âme de la bière,
c'est la signature du brasseur.
Il y a des brasseurs
qui me disent très souvent :
« Ma levure, elle a pas voulu
travailler ce matin.
Ma levure, c'est comme ma femme,
c'est comme ma compagne.
J'ai une maîtresse.
Elle est assez capricieuse
ma levure en ce moment.
Je ne sais pas ce qu'elle a,
elle a un truc,
mais j'y peux rien du tout.
C'est comme ça, ma levure,
j'y peux rien, elle fait ce qu'elle veut.
Elle travaille beaucoup
et puis après elle se repose. Normal. »
Le grain d'orge et la levure ;
sitos en grec, le grain d'orge.
Le vin d'orge en Egypte,
c'est le Zitom.
La zythologie, c'est la science,
et l'étude des bières.
C'est un mot qu'on utilise
surtout en Belgique.
Vous savez maintenant ce que je suis,
je pense ?
Vous avez deviné ?
Eh oui, zythologue.
Expert bière, qu'est ce que c'est ?
C'est d'abord transmettre
la connaissance des bières,
à travers les dégustations.
C'est aussi raconter les histoires
des hommes et des femmes qui brassent
pour les faire partager, comprendre.
Pourquoi brassent-ils ces bières là ?
Dans le sud de l'Aveyron,
sur les contreforts du Larzac,
je vous dis d'aller rencontrer Baptiste,
c'est le fermier brasseur.
Il va vous expliquer
comment il cultive ses céréales,
comment il malte ses céréales,
comment il les fait griller,
comment il fait pousser ses houblons.
Dans le Jura, c'est Bruno.
Bruno, est restaurateur.
Il est devenu brasseur
et il va vous faire goûter
son impérial stout,
qu'il fait vieillir trois ans
dans des fûts de vin de paille.
Au bord du lac d'Annecy,
c'est Stéphanie,
la brasseuse des montagnes,
qui va vous parler
de sa blonde, blanche, noire
et qui va vous initier au brassage.
En Belgique, pas très loin de Liège,
dans l'abbaye de Val Dieu,
c'est une jeune femme qui est brasseuse.
Au cœur de cet abbaye absolument magique,
c'est Virginie qui va vous dévoiler
les secrets de sa triple.
Alors oui, j'entends souvent :
« Je n'aime pas la bière.
Je n'aime pas la bière. »
Vous n'aimez pas quel goût exactement ?
C'est l'amertume que vous n'aimez pas ?
Vous n'aimez pas quand c'est amer ?
Alors je vais vous accompagner
et vous proposer des bières
qui sont fruitées, qui sont acidulées,
qui sont surettes,
qui sont épicées, chocolatées, florales.
Vous n'aimez pas les bières brunes,
ou les bières blanches,
ou les bières blondes ?
Vous n'aimez pas non plus
les bières rousses ?
Parce que c'est des phrases
que j'entends tout le temps.
Ça n'a pas tellement de sens à mon avis
parce que, une couleur,
ce n'est pas un goût.
A ce moment là,
je vais vous proposer par exemple,
je vais vous choisir une bière brune
épicée, une bière brune chocolatée,
une bière brune fruitée,
florale, une bière brune cacaotée.
En début d'atelier, j'ai eu
cette jeune femme qui me dit :
« J'aime pas la bière brune. » Très bien.
Son coup de cœur, en fin d'atelier,
c'est la bière la plus noire,
la plus torréfiée, au goût de café.
Et sur ce festival,
cette autre jeune femme me dit :
« Je n'aime pas la bière. »
Qu'est-ce que je vais bien
pouvoir lui faire goûter
pour qu'elle aime la bière ?
Ce nectar de malte
et de muscade-raisin,
de miel et de safran ?
C'est un bijou, un bijou.
La demoiselle le dédaigne.
Ce lambique acidulé, surette en diable ?
La demoiselle adore.
Une autre proposition,
une bière brune, vanillée,
chocolatée, complexe ?
Elle adore à nouveau.
Je pense que certains parmi vous,
peut-être,
pensent ne pas aimer la bière.
Je suis sûre, c'est certainement parce que
vous n'avez pas encore rencontré
les bières que vous pourrez aimer.
Ce regard neuf,
que vous posez sur les bières,
c'est mon moteur, mon ressort.
Merci à tous les brasseurs
et les brasseuses
qui créent tous les jours
des nouvelles bières.
La bière est en perpétuelle renaissance.
C'est la boisson la plus moderne qui soit
et en même temps
la plus ancienne de l'humanité.
Alors maintenant,
je vais partir à une dégustation,
vous venez ? Je vous emmène?
Allez, suivez moi.
(Applaudissements)